Володимир Зеленський запевняє, що хоче бути президентом, після якого в Україні з’явилися дороги,
і до кінця своєї каденції обіцяє відремонтувати всі державні дороги. А це понад 46 тисяч кілометрів.
Наприкінці року в інтерв’ю The New York Times Зеленський заявив, що за 2020-ий "зробили, й це підтверджено, чотири тисячі кілометрів доріг,
що перевищує загальну кількість кілометрів доріг, зроблених за попередні 10 років. За рік зробили в 10 разів більше, ніж за десять років у сумі".
При цьому його попередник Петро Порошенко не так давно заявляв, що саме за його правління 2018-ий рік
став рекордним щодо кількості відремонтованих автодоріг в Україні.
Мовляв, завдяки початку роботи Дорожнього фонду вдалося відновити 3800 кілометрів доріг.
Тобто майже стільки ж, як тепер стверджує Зеленський.
Ще кількома роками раніше на той момент міністр інфраструктури Володимир Омелян запевняв про рекордні ремонти доріг протягом 2016-2017 років.
Відремонтовано 3 000 кілометрів. Це рекордна протяжність за останнє десятиліття.
Це більше, аніж у рамках підготовки України до Чемпіонату "Євро-2012".
Водночас у 2012-му за президентства Віктора Януковича теж були гучні заяви про дорожні успіхи.
За даними тодішнього керівництва "Укравтодору", за два роки підготовки до "Євро" було зроблено у 19 разів більше, ніж за два попередні,
після будівництва, ремонту і реконструкції відкрили рух на нібито понад 3 000 кілометрів доріг.
Таким чином, якщо враховувати лише наведені дані, то за останні десять років до приходу Зеленського
в Україні мали б бути відремонтовані щонайменше 10 тисяч кілометрів доріг.
Це не збігається з твердженням президента, що 2020 року зробили вдесятеро більше, ніж за попередні 10 років.
Складається враження, що заяви про дороги майже без змін переходять у спадок - від Януковича до Порошенка, від Порошенка до Зеленського.
Президенти хваляться, а доріг нема?
Аби отримати офіційні дані про досягнення в межах президентського проєкту "Велике будівництво", Deutsche Welle звернулася до "Укравтодору".
Лише через понад місяць після запиту, тобто порушивши закон про доступ до публічної інформації,  держагентство надало відповідь.
І кількість відремонтованих доріг, які нарахував "Укравтодор", теж відрізняється від того, що заявляє Зеленський.
За оперативною інформацією Служб автомобільних доріг в областях у 2020 році "на автодорогах загального користування державного значення
на об’єктах будівництва, реконструкції, капітального та поточного середнього ремонту влаштовано 3 357 кілометрів верхніх шарів покриття".
Таке формулювання не дозволяє зрозуміти, скільки доріг саме побудували чи капітально відремонтували, а не просто вкатали верхній шар асфальту.
За словами експерта громадської кампанії "Європатруль", яка моніторить відповідність України євростандартам, В’ячеслава Коновалова,
деякі ділянки доріг в Україні справді відновили.
Утім, відповідь "Укравтодору" на запит DW, як і заяви політиків, експерт розцінює здебільшого як маніпуляцію цифрами і поняттями.
Приміром, чиновники рапортують у звітах, що відремонтовано 10 кілометрів дороги, а насправді у декількох місцях цієї ділянки просто підлатали,
замінили верхній шар асфальту та встановили нові відбійники.
Політики навмисно не конкретизують, які саме дороги зроблено, приписуючи до статистики ще й шляхи, за які відповідають місцеві органи влади, а не уряд.
Крім того, за словами експерта, чимало маніпуляцій з поняттями ямковий ремонт, технічна підтримка дороги тощо,
які можна трактувати за політичної доцільності як відновлення доріг або навпаки подібні роботи минулих років не включати у статистику,
щоб більш виграшно виглядати на фоні попередньої влади.
Нинішня ж влада не є винятком і навіть винахідливо грає поняттями, пояснюючи, чому гроші на "Велике будівництво" ідуть з "ковідного" фонду.
Мовляв, у грудні 2019-го Україна отримала від "Газпрому" 3 мільярди доларів, вигравши Стокгольмський арбітраж.
Ці кошти запланували на розвиток української інфраструктури.
Але коли пандемія коронавірусу "накрила" й Україну, ці гроші стали основою "ковідного" фонду.
Прем’єрміністр Денис Шмигаль підкреслює, що цей фонд називається фондом боротьби не лише з хворобою COVID-19,
а й її наслідками, серед яких - економічна криза.
Як приймалося рішення про виділення коштів на дороги… Усвідомлюємо.
Тобто ми рятували економіку і гроші, які були першопочатково на інфраструктуру, вони на інфраструктуру і повернулися…
Тобто ми не використовували гроші кудись, куди вони не були призначені.
Ми їх використовували туди, звідки їх брали на можливу боротьбу з ковідом у медичній площині.
Наприкінці минулого року Україна отримала і перший транш "коронапозики" від ЄС - 600 мільйонів євро.
Це, як кажуть у Єврокомісії, екстрена макрофінансова допомога, і вона не прив’язана до виконання якихось політичних умов.
На що будуть витрачені ці сотні мільйонів достеменно поки невідомо.
У Єврокомісії зазначають, що на збереження макрофінансової стабільності та на подолання соціально-економічних наслідків пандемії коронавірусу.
За логікою ж українського уряду під це формулювання може знову підпадати і ремонт доріг.
Адже, за словами прем’єра, влітку і особливо зараз основна проблема й основний страх українців -
не друга хвиля коронавірусу, а страх суспільства перед економічним проваллям.